Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Avez-vous un vieux rêve coincé ?
J’entends par là quelque chose que
vous avez envie de faire depuis longtemps,
mais où vous vous dites :
« Ça malheureusement,
ce n’est pas pour moi. »
Alors moi, j'en avais un très, très banal.
C’est le rêve de voler,
de voler comme un oiseau.
Ce qui s’en rapproche le plus,
c’est le vol en parapente.
Sauf que le parapente,
ce n’était vraiment pas fait pour moi.
Je suis papa de quatre enfants,
je suis très trouillard
et j’ai le vertige sur une taupinière.
Il y a quinze ans de ça,
j’ai quand même essayé
et depuis, j’ai découvert une activité
qui ne cesse de me surprendre.
J’ai d’abord découvert que personne
n’a le vertige en parapente,
même pas moi,
parce que le vertige, c’est quand
les pieds touchent par terre.
Ensuite, j'ai découvert ça.
Qu’est-ce que ça vous évoque ?
Est-ce Icare ? Peter Pan ?
Moi, la première fois que
j’ai vu ce type de vol,
je me suis tout de suite demandé
comment il échappe à la gravité.
Il n’y a pas de moteur,
ça ne vous a pas échappé !
Je ne le vous dirai pas car il faut
garder un peu de magie quand même.
Je découvre qu’on peut
faire des choses étonnantes,
comme plusieurs centaines de kilomètres
en une journée en parapente
sans poser le pied par terre.
Je vous explique comment :
la courbe rouge représente
les variations d’altitude du pilote
pendant tout son trajet.
Donc vous voyez qu’il oscille
entre quelques dizaines de mètres
et au maximum 2000 mètres d’altitude.
Vous voyez surtout qu’il monte
et qu’il descend sans arrêt.
Quand il monte, c’est qu’il a trouvé
une colonne d’air chaud,
une ascendance thermique.
Il l’exploite le plus possible, il monte
le plus haut puis il en cherche une autre.
Et s’il en trouve une autre,
il continue son vol.
Et ainsi de suite.
Donc, vous voyez que la compétence
qui est en jeu ici, dans ce type de vol,
c’est la lecture de l’invisible.
Être capable de lire une masse d’air,
qui est invisible,
et détecter à des endroits bénéfiques
des colonnes d’air chaud,
avec des signes complètement
cabalistiques.
C'est la forme des nuages, le vol
des oiseaux, la nature des sols.
Je découvre aussi une communauté.
Moi, je me faisais une espèce
d’image mentale du parapentiste
comme un être chimérique, un peu
entre Top Gun et le moniteur de ski.
Je vous présente Didier et Nanard,
qui sont deux de mes compagnons
les plus assidus de vol.
Ils volent comme des aigles,
mieux que moi, je dois le reconnaître,
parce qu’ils ont 40 ans
d’expérience derrière eux
et qu’ils ont cette vision de l’invisible
absolument incroyable.
Donc au final, je découvre une activité
assez facile d’accès,
mais à progression lente.
Une activité cérébrale, ou plutôt
réflexive, contemplative souvent.
En tout cas, très très loin de l’image
que j’avais du sport extrême.
Bon, c’est super tout ça.
C’est super sauf qu’il y a un hic,
ça n’aura échappé à personne.
Le hic, c'est le risque.
Ce sont les accidents de parapente.
Les accidents de parapente,
en moyenne, en France, il y a dix
à quinze morts par an, en parapente.
Il y a aussi des gens qui se blessent.
Dix à 15 morts,
si on rapporte ça à l’ensemble
des pratiquants, à peu près 25 000,
la plupart sont licenciés à
la Fédération française de vol libre,
ça nous fait un ratio de un mort pour
2000 pratiquants par an à peu près.
Donc oui, le parapente
est un sport à risque.
Je ne vais pas tenter
de vous vendre le contraire.
Ceci étant, ce ratio est très similaire
à deux activités aéronautiques :
l’avion de tourisme, c’est dans les mêmes
eaux, un sur 2000, le planeur idem.
L’ULM, l’ultraléger motorisé,
ça a l’air un peu plus dangereux.
Ce risque-là,
il percute - symboliquement -
tous les pilotes de parapente
à un moment donné.
Et il y a différentes stratégies
pour échapper à ça.
Il y a d’abord la stratégie
de l’autruche, le déni,
de dire : « Non, non, il n’y a pas
d’accidents de parapente. »
Et ensuite, la stratégie
de l’autruche de mauvaise foi
qui consiste à dire :
« Oui, bon, peut-être,
mais on peut aussi se tuer
en glissant sous la douche. »
Donc oui, c'est vrai, mais évidemment
ce n'est pas comparable.
S’il y avait une personne sur 2000 par an
qui prend une douche et qui se tue,
on aurait interdit la douche
depuis bien longtemps.
Il y a une autre stratégie :
« J’arrête, je ne fais pas de parapente. »
Éminemment respectable.
Et enfin, il y a une quatrième
stratégie qui consiste
à mettre tout en œuvre pour minimiser
son exposition au risque dans sa pratique.
C’est cette quatrième stratégie que
moi j’ai utilisée avec une variante :
je suis parti en croisade
contre les accidents de parapente.
Alors pas tout seul bien sûr.
Mais je suis devenu moniteur.
J'ai fait des dizaines de formations,
de conférences.
J’ai même écrit un livre dédié à ça :
« Réduire l’accidentalité en parapente. »
Je vous rapporte quelques nouvelles
du front de ma croisade.
Première question qu’on s’est posée :
comment se fait-on mal en parapente ?
Quels sont les scénarios
qui mènent à l’accident ?
La très bonne nouvelle,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas 36 000 façons
de se faire mal en parapente.
Il y a une douzaine d’accidents types
qui sont tous très bien caractérisés
et largement évitables.
Je vous en montre un.
Vous voyez ici un parapentiste
en vol au-dessus d’arbres.
Vous voyez, ça ne vole pas très haut.
Et peut-être vous arrivez à distinguer
dans le contre-jour un arbre, un seul,
qui est plus haut que les autres.
Je pense que vous devinez la suite.
Il a la caméra sur le casque,
donc le champ de vision suit
son regard, c’est pratique.
Et vous allez voir qu’à un moment,
il regarde l’arbre.
Et c'est son erreur.
Ne vous inquiétez pas pour lui,
il est juste perché dans l’arbre,
il va très bien.
Mais cet accident-type, qui s’appelle
la focalisation sur l’obstacle,
c’est un grand classique et
ce n’est pas propre au parapente.
Quand vous regardez un obstacle,
vous allez dedans.
En vélo, en ski, en trottinette,
en parapente, c'est pareil.
Ce n’est pas magique.
Cela s'explique très simplement.
C’est dû au fait que quand
vous regardez quelque chose,
votre corps suit votre regard,
sinon ça fait mal au cou.
Or votre trottinette, ski, parapente,
il est piloté par votre corps.
Donc, c’est normal que vous
alliez où vous regardez.
Ou peut-être retenez ça :
la prochaine fois que vous avez
un obstacle qui apparaît devant vous,
ne le regardez pas trop longtemps.
Qui se fait mal en parapente ?
Est-ce au hasard, dans la population
des pratiquants,
le doigt de Dieu qui en sélectionne
un de temps en temps
ou y a-t-il un profil type de pilote
qui est plus à risque que d’autres ?
Est-ce, par exemple, chez les débutants
qui regardent trop les arbres ?
Pas du tout.
C’est même complètement l’inverse.
On a observé une très, très claire
surreprésentation des pilotes expérimentés
parmi les accidentés et spécialement
parmi les accidents les plus graves.
Le haut de la pyramide des pilotes
expérimenté dans la communauté,
c’est bien sûr les moniteurs de parapente.
Les moniteurs de parapente,
ils ont deux fois plus de risques
de se tuer que les non moniteurs.
Retenez ce facteur deux.
Alors pourquoi ?
Est-ce parce qu’ils volent plus ?
Donc ils sont plus exposés.
Est-ce parce que leurs compétences
techniques les ouvrent à des pratiques
qui sont plus engagées ?
Ou est-ce que parce que leur compétence
technique les met dans un état
de surconfiance et de sous vigilance ?
C'est probablement un mélange de tout ça,
mais en tout cas, on a voulu tester
l’hypothèse de la surconfiance.
Pour ça, on a posé une question sournoise
à l’ensemble des pratiquants
licenciés, des 25 000,
et on leur a demandé :
« Par rapport à la moyenne
des autres pilotes,
est-ce que vous vous sentez -
risque perçu -
plus à risque, moins à risque, ou pareil ?
Déjà, personne ne se sent plus à risque,
jamais, nulle part.
À peu près 20% dans la
population générale se dit :
« Je suis moins à risque que les autres. »
Donc ils sont en confiance.
Ce qui est intéressant, c’est quand on
regarde ce qu’ont répondu les moniteurs
à cette question-là.
Et les moniteurs,
bingo !
Ils sont deux fois plus nombreux à
s’estimer moins à risque que les autres.
D’accord ?
Vous vous souvenez ?
Ils ont objectivement deux fois plus
de risques de se tuer, mais néanmoins,
ce n’est pas ce que ressent un certain
nombre d’entre eux, en tout cas.
Donc oui, phénomène de surconfiance,
probablement pour certains d’entre eux.
La surconfiance, ce n’est pas
qu’en parapente que c’est embêtant.
En voiture, ça peut jouer des tours,
ça peut faire perdre des élections.
Ça peut fragiliser des couples,
éventuellement.
La dernière question qu’on s’est posée,
une question presque philosophique,
c’est : « Quelles sont les causes
profondes des accidents de parapente ? »
Quand on analyse les accidents,
ce qui est un peu mon pain quotidien,
on s’aperçoit qu’il y a un point commun
à l’ensemble des accidents de parapente.
Un point commun qui permet de
les comprendre et de les expliquer.
Et ce point commun,
c’est qu’on peut tous les comprendre
comme des défauts de cohérence
dans les choix du pilote, de cohérence.
Ça tombe bien.
Choix de type de parapente,
choix de type de pratique,
choix de compagnon de vol,
choix de conditions météo
dans lesquelles on se met en l’air.
Donc au final cette notion de cohérence,
elle est même devenue centrale
dans les messages de prévention
de la Fédération de vol libre.
Vous avez une affiche de prévention :
« plaisir et sécu dépendent
de la cohérence de vos choix »
et pas d’autre chose.
Évidemment, ce n’est pas facile
de garder le cap de la cohérence
quand on fait du parapente,
parce qu’on est soumis
à des émotions qui sont fortes.
Parce que ça n'a rien, mais rien de
naturel d'être à 2000 mètres d'altitude,
suspendu à des ficelles,
à un truc qui ressemble à un drap.
Ça n’a rien de naturel.
Donc du coup, stress, peur,
oui, ça peut arriver.
Euphorie, parfois, ça peut arriver aussi.
Frustration.
La frustration de ne pas voler,
de ne pas pouvoir voler.
Surconfiance, parfois, on la vit.
Ce n'est pas facile de tenir la cohérence
sous pression d'émotions fortes.
Ce n’est pas facile,
mais c’est passionnant.
Parce qu’évidemment, chemin faisant,
sur ce chemin de la cohérence,
on va apprendre énormément sur soi-même.
Ce n’est pas facile,
mais ça vaut peut-être le coup.
Enfin, moi, je pense que ça vaut le coup,
parce que, moyennant
cette exigence de la cohérence,
alors, on se retrouve avec un accès VIP
à un des plus vieux rêves de l’homme,
le rêve d’Icare, ce n’est pas rien.
Sans la chute à la fin, ou en tout cas en
minimisant les risques de chute à la fin.
À ce stade, j’imagine que
vous êtes divisés en deux.
L'essentiel d'entre vous va demain matin
se précipiter dans une école de parapente
et je me réjouis vraiment
de partager le ciel avec vous.
Pour tous les autres, peut-être
pouvez-vous vous rappeler du rêve coincé,
vous savez, l’activité qui
n’est pas faite pour vous.
Et si, comme moi avec le parapente,
vous vous trompiez ?
Et s’il y avait moyen de la pratiquer à
votre façon, de la faire à votre main,
cette activité ?
Cela ne vaudrait-il pas le coup
d’essayer, juste le temps de tester ?
Après tout, vous n’êtes pas à l’abri
d’une agréable surprise,
dans le ciel ou ailleurs.
C’est ce que je vous souhaite. Merci.
(Applaudissements)